[Music]
hey
here we are it's monday hopefully we got
a sound check right yeah okay
i mean looks microphone looks like it's
working well that doesn't mean anything
as we discovered
here let me see
but um yeah looks like yeah all
our [ __ ] main regulars are in the
comments section t's here t-hubby's here
mango you see here also known as the
badger
got a bee's nest got louie louie
hernandez is in
pat's in looks like looks like
everybody's here not everybody's here
but a lot of a lot of our main ones are
here
okay so um kind of sleepy right now i
eat some cup ate some cupcakes
yeah so those valentine's cupcakes that
sophie sent us we're trying to like
space them out so i don't gain 400
pounds but so i've just been eating like
one
one a day a day yeah and the
so yeah we just ate one they're
delicious making that butter chicken
though too man i had that
i had that chicken in there marinating
two days made some indian butter chicken
because you did it and then we forgot
about it and then we went to red lobster
and eight and then we were like oh [ __ ]
that was all this chicken in there yeah
that's like that chicken marinating
those spices for like two days it's
really good it came out really good this
time so um
but a bowl of butter chicken and a
cupcake that's about all that's my
calorie
yeah that's my calories for the day
that'll hurt you i was laying down in
the bed and i forgot all about the show
my eyes were starting to droop
i know it was like eight minutes till it
started and i ran in there and i'm like
are you ready and he's laying there and
pookie's laying next to you
oh yeah sure it's okay we're already
prepared for this one because
we saw this one last night paid 20
to stream it because it only just came
out just came out the thing about it was
it was supposed to come out in theaters
back in october
but of course that didn't happen but
they did do um
they did that thing where they do a
simultaneous limited theatrical release
so this is playing in theaters and some
you know limited capacity yeah and then
they dropped it on um
you know vod as well and this only i
think it came out
friday so this is very very very recent
i was like jenny man i want to see this
movie the trailer looked good
it said the 20 is steep and she goes
well i'll go half on it
yeah that's that's what that's what a
movie cost 10 bucks
10 bucks ahead more or less i was like
all right yeah we'll do that
because i really really wanted to see
yeah okay okay yeah
it's like here i'll send you 12 that'll
make you feel better
all right so movie you can tell from the
trailer you can see it if you want
um nicholas cage plays a dude who's kind
of a
drifter he's a [ __ ] badass or he's
this
badass drifter and his
he loses all four tires of his car
because he accidentally
runs over some police spikes that got
left out
and uh they tell him to the toe thing
and the toe
the toe uh or the the repair people they
don't have
internet they're way out in the middle
of the [ __ ] country they don't have
internet
i think it's supposed to be nevada but
they shot it in georgia it's in george
you tell it's the south
yeah they don't they don't have internet
and they don't have an atm machine they
can't take credit cards so they said
well i'll tell you what
if you clean up uh uh really what's
called
willie's wonderful release wonderland uh
over the night
in the morning i'll come by and i'll
bring you your car not you know we'll
call it evening it's a thousand dollars
[ __ ] for towing and and we and and
and tires so he's like all right so he
goes in there and it's like chuck e
cheese it's like a place like chuck e
cheese's but it's abandoned they're
gonna reopen
it and uh turns out it's [ __ ] haunted
it's the the animatronic animals
come to life and one by one started
[ __ ] attacking him
turns out there's some kids that know
about it you can find all this out from
the trailer so i'm not spoiling anything
yeah
turns out some [ __ ] some kids know about
it and went down there to burn the place
down
they saw him in there and one of them
the cute girl goes in there
to try to she's like we can't burn it
down with him in there
she gets [ __ ] caught up and
eventually all the all the kids
uh end up going in there and get caught
up with all these damn monsters
all right um that's all i'm gonna say
uh i'm just gonna say now spoilers
kind of a spoiler well not really
spoiler you can find it
nicholas cage doesn't say a [ __ ] word
in this movie that's not a single word
he acts only with his face and it's
awesome
the movie's awesome i wasn't sure
because one of you guys one of you guys
said in the comments yesterday that he
doesn't say anything in it
and that kind of maybe it didn't make me
not want to watch it but i was like i
bet it probably won't be as fun because
half of the fun of nicolas cage cage in
the [ __ ] out is being like
and like you know doing that kind of
[ __ ] so i was kind of like i had mixed
feelings about what it was going to be
like of just watching a whole movie of
him not talking
but in a way i think it i think it
worked out i mean
he still cages the [ __ ] out he cages the
[ __ ] out with his face and just with his
body he cages the [ __ ] out you'll see
um yeah it was a good movie it was real
good i put it up there with
okay i'm gonna say it's on par with with
mandy
and uh color out of space it's a very
different kind of movie tone wise
it's it's kind of like satire it's
horror comedy
it goes over the top it tries to be
[ __ ] ridiculous
but it works the tone is is just right
for this kind of movie
they're trying to tell you an epic
mythological tale of a badass
yeah you just [ __ ] bad now it is he
is a badass but it is funny too
it's [ __ ] funny a lot of people i've
seen a lot of people compare this to
uh five nights at freddy's a lot of
people have compared this to the banana
splits movie
um which i still haven't got around to
seeing but
um it really has
it's hard to explain i really really
liked um
one the fact that he doesn't talk and
another thing too
and like i said this maybe is mild
spoilery but they don't tell you
anything about his backstory
you don't even find out what his name is
like his character doesn't have a name
and um and but i liked that it made him
almost kind of like a mythological
because he comes in here and starts
fighting these [ __ ]
possessed animatronic like willy the
weasel and
what were some of the other ones like
willie the weasel one was a chameleon i
think
yeah one was uh siren sarah or something
she was like a siren like a fairy
and uh there was some and they were all
like obviously like really sinister
looking
like just like like chuck e cheese um
essentially
um so so he's just in there fighting
them but they don't really
say like what like where he got this
badassery from or where he came from and
where he's going
but it doesn't matter and i liked that
they left that mysterious
doesn't matter also the running gag
through this movie of him
with his break times if you've seen the
movie you know
to do this [ __ ] job and they told him
to take [ __ ] regular breaks don't
forget to take regular breaks
so he programmed that [ __ ] in his watch
and you never can tell all of a sudden
[ __ ] will [ __ ] take a break
he's like you're taking a break now the
[ __ ] takes the fight the monster
yeah and then plays pinball
and it made me laugh every year and it's
just
it's a running gag so they do it a bunch
of times but it's like it's just every
time it happened it made me laugh even
harder
movies got an excellent um score and it
has some songs in it too real good
soundtrack
it's all most of them are by real uh an
original
artist what's his name emily and boy i
think is what his name is
uh there's also a couple there's a cover
in there i don't know if moy did the
cover or if that was
free birds in that no that was actual
free birds i [ __ ]
laughed when that [ __ ] went on yeah
as soon as that started up i was just
kind of like
i really really yeah i liked the score
and like the guy did
he even wrote like a willy's wonderland
theme song
and it's kind of like a dark wave kind
of it's good
it's kind of like dark wave new retro
waves some of it you can tell is uh
some of the background music tonal music
is kind of like um
uh kind of like goth industrial kind of
sounded like vnv nation in certain spots
he he could change the texture i didn't
know it was the same artist
doing it but they got the right guy
doing yeah i think he did i think he did
pretty much all the music for it except
for free bird and
um i think he did the voice of
willy the weasel yeah like one of the
animatronic characters and he might have
done some of the other voices too
yeah but so all of the songs that willy
sings
because he sings him like some all
sinister like the six little chicken
song that he does and
[ __ ] like that but that's all the same
guy like doing the [ __ ] color palette to
the movie was excellent kind of reminded
me of uh
kind of reminded me of uh what was that
what the vfw
yeah yeah yeah where it was like inside
it was like really really dark in this
inside of this like restaurant
colors with like magenta and cyan
lighting very dark and very colorful at
the same time and he's
uh it's a cool car action in the
beginning you know
they're just a bunch of little shout
outs to machismo like he's [ __ ]
driving a damn new camaro and
it's just over the [ __ ] top a lot of
just the the tone
they nailed it they nailed the tone good
writing
good storytelling i never i didn't get
bored at any time
i didn't lose any of my attention
there's a
good cast the casting's good when they
cast the kids i'm calling them kids
they're they're
they're they're in their 20s yeah
they're like late teens yeah
18 early 20s well they're pretending to
be teenagers but i think the actors are
in their early 20s
yeah um there's some sex appeal in the
movie there's cute girls in it so there
there's good looking guys in it so
they're trying to appeal to a good
audience and um
it's pretty gory there's some good gold
yeah there's animatronic destruction
[Laughter]
it's you're not dealing with a hollywood
movie it's
it's from a very small studio it's a
good uh
what do you call it uh independent
filmmakers
but it top-notch production you know for
for the budget
kind of like vfw now interestingly from
what i could determine
maybe yeah yeah now this movie was
written by
somebody named geoparsons who i think i
don't know if this is their first
uh theatrical movie i think they're more
like a theater person
like they had written stuff for the
stage and they had written
and i guess their agent or whatever like
told them hey you should write a movie
screenplay
like you know to diversify your career
or whatever so apparently he wrote this
and put it up on something called
bloodlist which i guess is
something where you put like horror
screenplays and like people can
and i guess nicholas cage saw it on
there and thought the idea was cool
and because nicholas cage is a
co-producer on this as well
yeah he wanted to do this right so
apparently he wanted it now what i heard
i don't know if this is true or not but
the whole thing about him being mute in
this
because i think a lot of people were
kind of like oh man it's like half the
fun of watching nicolas cage is just
like watching him screaming and yelling
and stuff
i didn't notice that he was but i didn't
yeah but it's like i and i kind of felt
like that too but then when i watched
the movie i was just kind of like oh
it's fine
it's the tone of the movie and the
character he's
a lot of the [ __ ] that he's doing he's
doing by himself so there's nobody for
him to talk to for a while
people do show up and then they kind of
play at the fact that the dude doesn't
talk
and that's part of his badassery is that
he's not really gonna [ __ ] talk to
you you just gotta see the [ __ ] face
he's acting with his face he does cage
the [ __ ] out
but he doesn't he does it physically
you'll see it
it's it's a uh he's a he's
he's supposed to be a strong silent type
he doesn't have to talk
yeah but he's in the movie almost
constantly
yeah pretty much i mean there's other
characters that come in there but that's
not till later
you get lots of cage time lots of lots
of dick cage time
and uh yeah they're talking but uh yeah
you so it's not like that last one we
did
uh uh what was the name of the [ __ ]
one with the aliens uh
it's not like jiu jitsu no jiu jitsu he
talked this was much better they had a
very little
screen time this was like a lot better
than she did
this is up there with uh with with mandy
i think
it's it's good it's a very different
movie than mandy but
to me it kind of reminded me a little
bit more vfw
kind of had that tone yeah it felt a bit
like uh
in some ways it felt kind of like a
really good carpenter movie in
in a way except funnier funnier than
what carpenter would do
yeah it's a lot funnier um
it's funny but it's it's comedy horror
you know what i mean yeah you never you
don't get scared in it but you never you
know
it's not scary you know what's funny but
it's not in certain places
it's funny because they don't even have
this listed as a horror or horror comedy
they have it listed as action adventure
that's probably what i would call it
which i don't know what i would have
called it
i would call it horror comedy but yeah
just because it's real gory and if
you're not into gore it's probably going
to be like oh what the hell
like action adventure when you say
action adventure i think of like
jurassic park
yeah you know well there's kind of that
element i can
well you know i can i can give one more
thing away
because it's mentioned in the trailer
the kids are coming to burn the [ __ ]
place down because they know about it
and they
they know that the animatronics and
they're possessed
and they're possessed by demons it's not
demons they're not yes
not exactly you'll see yeah and uh
it's possessed and they're they try to
warn
the nicholas cage character you never
know his name yeah they just call him
the janitor
in the yeah and he wasn't even a janitor
that was just a job they offered him
yeah like to pay for the car yeah
because he didn't have a thousand
dollars
try to warn him that uh that that he's
not there to clean up that he's actually
there
because the place is run by a cult and
they're sacrificing him
that he's gonna be a human sacrifice
so there's an element of that you'll see
if you watch it
is it worth 20 yeah yeah i thought it
was
i wish they would have sold it to me for
20 and not rented it to me for 20 yeah
because it's
i mean 20 is a little steep yeah it's a
little steep
but we did have a good time watching it
yeah i mean i had a guy i had a really
good time with it
i bought it from xbox or reddit from
xbox and they kind of had it listed as
um early release okay that that was like
an
early release price a rental price
that's what they claim
it came out february 12th all right and
it's in theaters too
but i don't know if it's played any
theaters here it's probably just playing
in big cities i would imagine
you wait a few days it might go down
some
yeah usually if you wait a few weeks
it'll go down to like
nine bucks or 9.99 and then it'll go
down to 6.99 or whatever
i just think it's really funny that like
we watched jiu-jitsu which is also
pretty new
and we bought that for like four bucks
yeah
but they said it's like he had 20
dollars but this is what this was way
way way better
[Laughter]
way better because i just i mean and and
like i said i can't
stress enough i did watch a couple of
other reviews of this most people are
really really digging it some people
said they didn't like because they
thought the editing was too kinetic you
couldn't really tell what was going on
um which i don't know i didn't really
get that impression like it does some of
the editing is kind of like artistic and
it has
you know like all this kind of light and
lens flare and stuff
but it's like i don't know it didn't
really bother me and like i said the the
score is really cool
[ __ ] like that but um you know
it's this was this was just like a
really really entertaining
fun gory i mean [ __ ] man
nicholas cage fighting possessed
animatronic weasels yeah no tell me you
don't want to watch that
you can't maybe the fee they paid cage
didn't cover him talking no it didn't
because that's not the case he'd already
seen the script he wanted to do this
uh he thought it would be interesting to
do it without talking
yeah it's um if when you see it it makes
a lot more sense
when you watch it it fits the tone of
the movie because
he's such a [ __ ] badass in the movie
that he's that he shouldn't have to talk
it'll make sense
it makes more sense when you see it it's
funny it's funny
he's almost kind of like portraying him
as like a almost like a character in a
western
yeah like where he's like coming into
this dinky ass little town and they have
a problem
kind of like something clint eastwood
and he sorts it out even though they
didn't ask him to sort it out they were
actually just going to [ __ ] him over but
he just sorts it out anyway like
kind of like high plains drifter when
cleveland clint eastwood shows up he
doesn't say much maybe like well
okay just says little one-liners and
stuff you know
except this guy's so bad as he doesn't
say even say a one-liner he's just
you just but it's written to where it
makes sense you know it's the
part of the tone of the movie and like
he was good and like i said i think that
i really liked that he didn't they
didn't give him a name they didn't give
him a backstory he basically just turns
up in this town
you don't know who he is you don't know
where he came from you don't know
you know why he seems like so
uh blase about the situation you don't
like you don't know anything yeah and i
think that that's really good i
i liked that and like i said i i said
earlier it's like maybe people
maybe other people wouldn't think it was
funny as i thought but that whole
like taking breaks thing it's every
single time that happened it just kept
getting funnier i don't know why it just
kept
getting funnier t's hubby says okay on
par with mandy i'm so
it's on par with mandy in terms of how
much i enjoyed it
in that same realm i prefer mandy just
because they had
[ __ ] it was that movie was just so
goddamn weird and it was really creative
this one too it's also creative it did
some [ __ ] to surprise me i was laughing
at it
the tone is very different mandy was
kind of like
kind of weird and disturbing and then
funny at certain parts this one's funny
through the whole thing
uh but there's a lot of action a lot of
gore i would put it
tonally and just the way it looked kind
of visually
on par with a movie called vfw yeah
which we would reviewed that a while
imagine if you had vfw going on
inside of a damn abandoned chuck cheese
shoe biz pizza and it's
it's not meant to it's not really meant
to be taken
seriously it's satire but you can relate
to it because you know
you've been to places like this and you
know people like this and just it's got
a lot of good
supporting actors in there doing the
other characters
um certain things kind of unfold it gets
a little more complicated as it goes uh
the animatronics are [ __ ] up
uh they're some of them are human some
of them are animals
yeah one's like there's an alligator
there's an alligator there's a big old
weasel
there's a weasel's mexican turtle
yeah is he he has a sombrero and he
speaks spanish speaks spanish and he's
he's subtitled
i love that and then they got a they got
a [ __ ] scene with a girl in the neck
they got a siren which looks like a
teenage girl with a damn [ __ ]
she looks kind of like uh tinkerbell
tinkerbell really like she comes with
whips she's big ass
she tries and then there's a chameleon
yeah there's chameleon [ __ ] chameleon
that talks [ __ ] to you and [ __ ]
you just gotta see it yeah it's pretty
funny
it's pretty funny yeah um somebody's
asking
about uh who here likes star trek
i like star i like the original series
obviously well i have
i have mirror image spots back there yep
star trek
sophie got me that for my birthday yeah
if you like if you like star trek the
original series go check out uh
star trek continues free on youtube in
hd that one was good
i liked that one too it's the final
season of the original series
and yeah it's fan made and they yeah
when you look at it it's just like it's
just like the old movies yeah
or the old tv show and it's the acting
and the writing is really good had a lot
of the same people that worked on the
original
show and also had people that worked on
next generation and everything
and it has the second part of the mirror
episode where
that mirror spock was in it's what miro
spock did
back in the mirror universe you know
what what ended up happening during his
revolt
and i think that's like episode four uh
i think it's called
uh fairest of them all did that was
called
or was i think it was called fairest of
them all oh yeah maybe yeah
it would yeah yeah it's good yeah one of
the one of the better mirror episodes
actually i think
yeah it was one of the best mirror
episodes in the whole star trek universe
was that was was the one from star trek
continued
i've seen like some of the other series
like you showed me enterprise and i've
seen some like d space and i've seen
some of the other ones like off and on
but i think the original series is the
only one that i've sat through like
probably three times
you know like the entire series because
i just i just like all those characters
and
i just like the whole 60s badger just
synthetic
badger says he's just going to go ahead
and buy this movie on blu-ray yeah i
mean if
if the price is similar you can just
yeah i mean
it's you might as well like if you're
going to pay 20 to rent it i mean you
might as well just like buy it
if it's available i don't know if it is
yeah i'm not yeah like i said it's it's
it might not be yet because as i said
it's still in like limited theatrical
release and they only just released it
like a couple of days ago like three
days ago literally
so yeah louie there there's a there's an
animatronic monster in there i think
it's a turtle
that dressed up in some i think it's a
turtle like at first i i
first i thought it was a bird maybe a
parrot or something it's hard to tell
but then the first one
the first one that gets killed that
nicolas cage kills is an
ostrich it was an ostrich right yeah
that's an ostrich
okay so i'm guessing they didn't have
two birds so i think there was one there
was one that was an alligator yeah it's
a mexican i think it's a mexican turtle
it's speaking spanish and it's subtitled
it's [ __ ] hilarious
that was another very funny scene like
it was like it was short but it's like
that one with the girl like beat notice
yet that was like really funny
oh and also i want to mention too that
the woman that plays the sheriff in this
town
is the same woman who uh
the sparkle motion lady from donnie
darko
who was questioning your commitment to
sparkle motion yeah it was that lady
so she was in it too as the sheriff and
then it was just kind of like like i
said i think i didn't realize that it
was supposed to be
nevada when i was watching it i just saw
that on the wikipedia page
but they actually shot it in georgia i
don't know why they didn't just make it
georgia
in the movie because it doesn't really
matter but um
i don't know so so it was just like this
little good old boy town that has like
800 people in it or something
yeah and it's just kind of like somebody
just found a channel yesterday's been
been
binge watching us for 18 hours yeah yeah
he's been crazy
well yeah because he's been like uh
commenting on a lot of the older videos
and stuff because i was uh answering
some of the
some of the stuff but yeah he's been
trying to catch up on all the
i was gonna take you a while man we've
been when did we start this show 2016.
i don't know man it's been that long i
think so
yeah we've been doing this four or five
years and uh we do more shows now than
we used to because i think we used to
just do like one or two a week and now
we do a show pretty much every day at
least one i can't believe this show's
four years old
at least it might be longer i'm not i
know
i'm i'm making you tired just talking
about it
i'm going [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
getting old four [ __ ] years soon you
die
yeah i die
tomorrow i start them damn injections
i'm gonna feel a lot better
well if they call they were they they
called her they called him and then they
were like uh
i said her because the ladies and she
called and she's like yeah we
we got your stuff and we have to order
the drugs now
so when the drugs come in they're going
to call him and then he has to ride down
there yeah
but he showed me where it was today
because it's just right there
because okay so you guys cause i know
one of you guys
um ordered a plisken shirt and then one
of you guys i'm sending
um yeah jason was getting a pliskin
shirt and
uh donovan or donny he was getting um
he wanted me to sign one of my books
like faces fill into
so i got that yesterday so i signed
everything we got the shirt made we got
everything packed up and then we went to
the damn post office
got the labels and i used the little
labels you know because you use the
little machine and you can pay for the
labels blah blah blah
and then it's like then i go to put it
in the mailbox and it's like kachonk and
it wouldn't open
it's locked it's p yeah i guess it's
president's day
so i guess they were like well we can't
have the [ __ ] opal like
the like the part is open where you can
use the machines but the actual
mailboxes are closed because i guess
they don't want them to fill up because
there's nobody there
but yeah so that's the book and that's
the t-shirt
so so we already paid for the postage we
just have to go tomorrow
and uh well hi pookie what you doing
listen i'm going on a juice tomorrow
not technically juiced is anabolics i
mean
juicy tom it's gonna be a [ __ ]
strange cocktail a [ __ ] couple
different kinds of testosterone and then
some pituitary gland
[ __ ] stuff i'm gonna get slightly
boosted
but they're gonna boost me back up to
kind of what the levels would be
like if you were maybe in your late 20s
or probably late late 20s
i have to see the numbers because you
get blood work every three
months tomorrow i'm going to look at my
blood work i haven't seen the numbers
yet i want to see what
what my free testosterone and by
availability and my [ __ ] total count
was
and i'm gonna see how that's gonna it's
probably bad it feels like it's bad
and then uh we'll start the treatment
and they're gonna [ __ ] boost me up
over time
what you doing pool she's rolling i'm
gonna run i'm gonna run that [ __ ]
dude
she was committed to that she was just
like getting excited
she was like fighting the carpets upside
down fighting the carpet with her back
feel better
okay she's crazy yeah she puts on
shows for us she does funny [ __ ]
oh my god but uh business says i inject
testosterone directly in my junk
damn that's hardcore i don't believe you
do
[Laughter]
no he's a joke he's a joker that doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if he goes
there
well i wouldn't do it but you know if
you want to do it like that i'm not
judging
most dudes their [ __ ] belly
or in their [ __ ] glute
well i'm not gonna i'm not i'm not
injecting testosterone into your butt so
you can just like forget about that
right now
you gotta try that [ __ ] see the world
through my eyes i've seen the [ __ ]
feet no
i can't i can imagine what the world
looks like through your eyes i don't i
don't need to know
i've seen the numbers on women and i'm
going like damn how can you live with
numbers like that but
it's just a different you're a different
sex uh
yeah just don't need as much of it no we
don't need as much as i can
man i'd be [ __ ] really sleepy with
that you're already really sleepy
yeah i know that because the male the
male
[ __ ] what do you call it the male
[ __ ] andrew consistent runs real hard
well that's not that's why we normally
like age in dog years
yeah that's why y'all die much earlier
well and plus dudes are more
prone to being stupid
it's making you do stupid [ __ ] but it
makes sense at the time
it's all that risk-taking behavior make
you sexy as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
paul moore says i hope they don't make
tom more hyper he'll be bouncing off the
walls that's what i said i said he's
gonna be rampaging all around the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'll be all right i'll work it out maybe
it'll just it'll keep you awake because
look you look like you're falling asleep
i know it is i had to go if you guys
like got here a little bit late i had to
go and get
like five minutes before the show
started eight minutes before the show
started okay i'll do
i'll be more accurate i had to run in
the into benchtop where where is he
because usually he comes in here like
10-15 minutes before
yeah and i had ran in there and he was
laying on the bed and pookie was laying
on the bed and i'm just like uh
are you ready to do the show oh i forgot
all about it as well
yeah yeah yeah it's because i just ate
that damn cupcake
yeah cupcake carbohydrates hit me
and it makes you [ __ ] sleepy man and
my agent [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you up
we're gonna take care of that tomorrow
though we'll take care of it yeah it's
because just the way your metabolism
runs
it it runs for me it ran good until i
hit about i don't know maybe
47 maybe and it started to kind of i
could feel it
a decline in it like like time was
stretching out
and i was slowing down and time was
speeding up but it felt like
yeah yeah although i kind of feel like
everybody has that like the older you
get the faster it seems like time is
going
and then you feel like you're like a
turtle moving through time
and you're [ __ ] sleepy and then by
the time i hit like 50 i'm like man
this this [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks and then
you go in there and start lifting and
stuff to try to [ __ ] get production
back up it does kind of come back
but it doesn't it's not enough yeah man
yeah it's not enough and then you can
start gaining size
but once you get to a certain size if
you get sore it takes 10 days to heal
all that up
that's not right it should be more like
three days
yeah that's what it would have been like
that's what it would have been like you
know
in my 30s or 40s about three days but
now it's like [ __ ] 10 days
and that's that's just one of the signs
when you go on real gear though like
[ __ ] anne of arts at 12 hours
you get right back in there that's why
those dudes are making [ __ ] 11 years
worth of [ __ ]
muscle gains in a year they're eating
like crazy just
pro protein synthesis machine hungry
crazy
you want to fight everything but you but
it's
you get big year then they start taking
mood enhancers it's a whole stack of
[ __ ]
yeah a mood [ __ ] what they call them
mood stabilizers to keep you from
[ __ ] going crazy stabilizer
stabilizing goddamn moves because you
[ __ ] do this man
[ __ ] roid rage that's why i don't go
don't go on it it's
don't go on that [ __ ] i'm not saying
don't do any of the [ __ ] gear
not unless you're a competition
bodybuilder uh because
make you [ __ ] crazy
it [ __ ] up your livers and if you do it
while you're young you got to stay on it
for so long that by the time you're 50
or 60 you're [ __ ] the shot
you're getting a heart valve [ __ ]
work at [ __ ] 50.
it's just not worth it when you're young
if you're dying you know you only got 25
years left do you want man [ __ ]
doctor told me he says dude it's your
age you could do whatever you wanted
it's not going to make a big difference
i was like i know you know
it meant difference in my lifespan yeah
you know
sorry i wanted to say a week i'm not
banged up we got somebody uh
new in here blackmagic film studios says
hey guys i liked your video about
sputnik that movie
movie's good too bit slow but nice hi
there black magic film studios what's up
welcome to the show so um
do you have anything else you would like
to add no that's about it see this movie
it's fun
please do one stream where you rank your
favorite horror movies
we you know what i've been wanting to do
that for like a year or two
that was one of the things i think that
that was one of the options that i threw
into the patreon poll for the halloween
special but it didn't get picked
no that's not we don't want to do that
for a normal show what we do is we do
that for
for a wednesday show that yeah that's
actually a good idea
make a list and get drunk and then rail
them all off
we'll read the list off and talk about
the movie
that goes and that's that's a whole
wednesday maybe we should do
maybe we should just kind of make a list
this wednesday or next wednesday
i started making a list a long time ago
but i don't know what happens
if you have a list around here we can do
it this wednesday i mean if you want me
to like rank them that's going to be
really hard
but i don't know i could maybe do it
i'll i'll do it okay i'll come up with
something
louis says that should be a saturday
night show well yeah i guess i don't
know
i think people will will not like that
because
they know they normally want one of
those
like true crime or paranormal [ __ ] or
something
yeah so that that should be a sidetrack
show
this show this show coming up this
saturday
uh is gonna be about uh the cult again
which one
the source family cult i don't know that
one
or maybe i do but don't remember it
which one was that
kind of like they were i think that they
were the first ones that opened like a
vegan restaurant
in california like back in the 60s but
they were kind of like
scared like i don't know hippies but oh
looking scary people yeah yeah yeah
i might add another one too it's
depending on how um
how much material there is about them
that i can find
um because they you know they are like a
really interesting story on their own
but
if if i feel like it's not gonna be
enough for you know
three or four hours then i'll throw
another cult in there too
but we'll see um all right i think
that's probably
but yeah let me write down edit uh
fave horror movies because then i can
start making this maybe i can find that
list that i made i wonder what the hell
i did with that
it was a while back i'm sure it's around
here in those piles of paper somewhere
um but yeah so we'll be back tomorrow
and tomorrow we're going to be talking
about
ouija and ouija origin of evil because
louis sent us the
movies and we just watched them so we're
going to talk about them tomorrow then
wednesday
we'll talk about our favorite horror
movies since you guys would like to do
that
and then tom's going to go take a nap
i'm going to take a nap and
maybe okay and uh and i'm going to
finish editing
my my life's latest book review and
we will see you guys tomorrow right
around the same time
thanks everybody for coming by bye